why are fast organizers called fast
in this video we'll see exactly how much
faster the so-called fast tokenizers are
compared to the slo-contour parts for
this benchmark we'll use the glue mli
data set which contains 432 000 spares
of text
we'll see how long it takes for the fast
and slow versions of a bird tokenizer to
process them all
we define our fast and slow tokenizer
using the auto tokenizer api
the first tokenizer is the default when
available so we pass along use fast
equal force to define the slow one
in a notebook we can time the execution
of the cell with some time magic command
like this
processing the wall data set is four
times faster with the fast organizer
that's weaker indeed but not very
impressive
this is because we pass along the text
to the tokenizer one at a time this is a
common mistake to do with fast
organizers which are backed by rus and
thus able to parallelize the
tokenizations of multiple texts
passing them only one text at a time is
like sending a cargo ship between two
consonants with just one container it's
very inefficient
to enrich the full speed of our fast
organizers we need to send them patches
of texts which we can do with a
particular true argument of the map
method
now those are impressive results the
fast technicians takes 12 seconds to
process the dataset that takes 4 minutes
to the slow tokenizer
summarizing the results in this table
you can see why we have called those
tokenizers fast and this is only for
tokenizing text if you ever need to
train a new tokenizer we do this very
quickly too